thank so much so i'm alex and i work at
google cloud i write critically on
machine learning and data including
machine learning fairness and today i'm
presenting a talk called responsible AI
practices fairness and machine learning
so what i want to talk about is some
problems in fairness and machine
learning what some problems and
challenges of developing tools for fair
tools and machine learning is and then
some solutions and stuff that we've come
at at Google it's you to do that so AI
has this so AI has the potential it's
rapidly growing in capacity impacted
influence so as designers and developers
of AI systems as many of you are in this
room or are aspiring to it's an
imperative to understand the ethical
considerations of our work a tech
centric view that solely revolves around
improving the capabilities of an
intelligent system doesn't sufficiently
consider human needs an ethical human
centric AI must be designed and
developed in a manner does align with
the values and ethical principles of a
society or to community effects and when
you talk about ethics ethics is based on
well founded standards of right and
wrong that prescribe what humans ought
to do usually in terms of rights
obligations benefits to society fairness
or specific virtues so we recognize with
such powerful technology it raises
equally powerful questions about its use
how AI is developed and used will have a
significant impact on society for many
years to come
so we've announced at Google as a leader
in AI we feel a deep responsibility to
get this right so we've announced seven
principles to guide our work going
forward so these aren't theoretical
concepts their concrete standards which
actively govern our research and product
development and actively impact our
business decisions you can check out all
of these in details at AI Google slash
principles I want to focus on one of
them today though and this is the second
one which is to avoid creating or
reinforcing bias the one in bold so what
does this mean well the
principal in full reads the following AI
algorithms and datasets to reflect
reinforce or reduce unfair biases we
recognize that distinguishing fair from
unfair biases is not always simple and
differs across cultures and societies
will seek to avoid unjust impacts on
people particularly those related to
sensitive characteristics such as race
ethnicity gender nationality income
sexual orientation ability and political
or religious belief I also want to
distinguish this bias from the bias in
the statistical sense here we're talking
about human biases we're not necessarily
talking about statistical biases
although these overlap sometimes so what
are some of the challenges in working
towards systems that are fair and
inclusive for all so the questions
aren't always obvious and easy so I want
to take a step back and look at the
whole of the machine learning pipeline
so if you're building a machine learning
pipeline you've collected some data if
it's a supervised learning case the
training data have to go through some
kind of labeling or annotation process
these can be labeled in-house and more
and more these are being delegated out
to crowd workers or an annotation
service after those first two steps
you're ready to be in training your
model you typically optimize for some
common metrics or objective function
then you're ready to serve new data is
fed into the model customers are
filtered recommendations are ranked and
stats are aggregated at the end of the
process people will see some kind of an
effect they're provided with a
particular service they see the serve
ads or product recommendations based on
the feedback to system we bring the you
begin the process all over again so
human behavior informs further data
collection I want to drill down a bit
and talk about the the first two bosses
in this though so unconscious bias
unconscious bias they exist in our data
and they exist in two forms
first there's the human biases that
exist in the data because data are found
in the world and data in the world has
existing biases related to properties
like gender race and sexual orientation
we can think of those biases in the
terms of the ways that they kind of
manifest in our data samples so there
could be reporting bias by our subjects
because they only choose to reveal
certain aspects of data about themselves
or their opinions they may be selection
bias that is those subjects that get
into our samples only represent a
privileged type of user there may be
over generalization where our sample is
our only representative of a particular
type of user and there may be algorithm
engine hub engine dating bias where we
think that people who are not on a
sampler are homogeneous whereas the
people who are in our sample are diverse
in nuanced second we can also run into
human biases which arise as part of our
data collection and labeling procedures
confidence and confirmation bias refer
to overconfidence in our hypotheses only
looking for data which may confirm our
hypotheses the Spiritist bias refers to
potentially influencing our subjects
through the process of data collection
and automation biases refer to biases
which crop up when the data that we get
is solely the data which is easily
automatable only the things that we can
collect
okay so we're missing something there
and the problem with this is that since
we're starting with data with machine
learning that's going to reflect
problems downsample we're going to have
skewed data our model is going to be
skewed and we're going to have
potentially biased outcomes in in this
and so what enters is we have a machine
learning pipeline that looks like this
but it also can potentially have human
bias at every point of it so we have to
think about what kinds of data are
accessible does the availability of data
privileged a particular type of user
does it put another group at a
disadvantage
what transformations are you making sure
data which may exclude one group
compared to another you can also appear
in the process of labeling where the
human biases that human annotators are
introducing to your data how stable your
categories of classification and it can
occur at the model level does a
particular objective but certain
subgroups of people at a disadvantage
compared to a group in aggregate and so
these biases are going to appear dams
downstream we start doing serving other
models so the first big problem that we
run into when creating a machine
learning system is this email problems
learn from existing data collected from
the real world and so an accurate model
may
or even amplify problematic pre-existing
biases on the data based on race gender
religion or other characteristics so I'm
gonna give you an example so some
research that a team that within Google
led by Ben Packer they wrote this up in
a great blog post looking at what
happens when we consider gender and race
in and word embeddings okay well if
you're not familiar with word embeddings
I figure many of you are but if you're
not they convert an input text into an
output vector numbers so in the process
and and in the process map semantically
similar words near each other in the
embedding space so given a train text
embedding model we can directly measure
the association's the moral has between
words or phrases so many of those
associations are expected or helpful
from language natural language
processing tasks and text embeddings are
usually trained on electric
electronically available karappa such as
Google News text and so this is the
classic line from The Big Lebowski and
the rub really tied the room together
and that gets mapped into a vector space
so what Bandon esteemed in they wanted
to see how this would affect downstream
tasks in natural language processing so
say you want to build a sentiment
analyzer for your movie for movie
reviews and use pre chained text and
betting's to do so so you white might
want to use the IMDB data set to select
negative or positive examples of what's
what's positive and what's negative and
to show bias you say I'm going to append
the phrase reviewed by and then put a
name to understand the different types
of biases which appear in classification
due to different types of names so what
this plot shows is a difference in
average sentiment scores on modified
test sets where the phrase reviewed by
plus a plus a name had been added to the
end of each review so the violin plots
show the distribution over differences
when models are trained on small samples
of the original IMDB training data so
most of the training so we have a
difference here we have African American
names versus European American names and
then female names versus male names and
then of various various different types
of pre turing texts and beddings for the
universal sentence decoded a glove where
Tyvek know
I'm betting it all and then also the
slaughter today I know LM ones so most
of the pre train Texan betting models is
it some kind of Euro American named bias
meanwhile this the universal sentence of
cutter exhibits a large bias and
indirection of positiveness for male
names all the NLL m50 exhibits a strong
female name bias so you might be asking
ok sentiment analysis of movies might
not have many cents of subsidy
downstream effects but it's also easy to
see how this could have downstream
effects and other types of sentiment
analysis in cases in which AI is being
used to supplant human judgement another
example say you're building a messaging
app that generates suggested replies
such as smart reply in Gmail you might
have a set of candidate replies for
incoming messages and you need to choose
between candidate replies one way you
could do that is you could prepare
vectors generated by your word
embeddings with the original query in
this case we look at the cosine
similarity between and candidate vector
in the vector from the original query so
in this case you have some kind of
message like is is you get an email says
is the captain here today your
candidates are yes she is
yes he is and then for that you can
generate a score for each and the bias
for is a difference between a two and so
for this you create a template at a list
of it responses that include is was your
blank a and basically it's a template of
is the occupation here today or and then
we generated a set of these and then the
responses as being one of one of two of
these binary gender options in which the
pronoun she or he is inserted and so for
a given occupation over all the models
bias score is a sum of the bias force
for all the question answered templates
without occupation the scores that skew
more positive or biased towards female
pronouns and those which have negative
or bias [ __ ] and male pronouns so
looking at the table we have things
which are typically dominated by by
women traditionally made which is not
necessarily a gendered word waitress is
necessarily gender word but other things
like Midwife reception
nanny nurse not necessarily gendered and
reflect existing stereotypes in in the
data on the other side you have in those
words in occupation seasonally the
highest male bias Undertaker which is
kind of interesting
janitor referee plumber but then you
also have ones down like philosopher
philosophy which is a most of humanity
is the field that has the highest male
to female inequality of all the
humanities but then you also have terms
that have high status markers such as
president coach captain maestro and
something to bathe specific attention to
you engineer so we've seen that these
pre trained Texan betting since they're
trained on existing core Appa are
exhibiting those biases that exist in
the real world and we have to consider
whether how that's going to affect our
models downstream okay so that's
challenge one chance to is that even
with the most rigorous and
cross-functional training and testing it
is a challenge to ensure a system will
be fair across all situations and for
this example I want to talk about an API
the perspective API developed by jigsaw
which is a part of alphabet and it's a
tool intended to be used in a wide range
of cases such as supporting human
comment moderation' providing feedback
to comment authors and allowing comment
viewers to control their experience and
so what it does is it assigns a toxicity
score to particular comments toxic this
is fine as a rude disrespectful or
unreasonable comment that is likely to
make one leave a conversation so the
jigsaw team collected specialized data
sets from comment sections in the New
York Times and Guardian Wikipedia talk
pages and they collaborated with groups
such as the anti-defamation league and
gules employee resource groups to
identify toxic language they also worked
within the academic community they went
to the fairness accountability and
transparency conference they ran a
workshop and they invited victims of
harassment to identify toxic language so
the problem with this is that
they started to see things in which
terms or sentences we're generating
toxic high toxicity scores that didn't
warrant it and the problem is that the
existing data sets are small or they
have parsed phosphorylations well more
seriously to the toxicity model learned
that several incorrect associations
between toxicity and identities are
frequently under attack so for instance
the Gay and Lesbian Film Festival starts
today really high toxicity score of 0.8
to stating that an event is happening
today being transgender is independent
of sexual orientation a statement about
differences between between gender
identity and sexual orientation toxicity
the score of 0.5 to a Muslim is someone
who follows her practices Islam
toxicities for of 0.46 literally the
definition of a Muslim as having a high
toxicity score okay so this is a problem
and so the jigsaw team did a work this
paper by by Lucas Dixon and colleagues
really try to disentangle what this is
so I won't go into the different metrics
that they what they that they generated
called pin area under the curve but you
check out the paper if you're interested
in them but this qualitative analysis
which comes from a forthcoming paper by
Meg Mitchell and other folks in the ML
fairness team highlights the drastic
ways that models can change after
testing and biased mitigation strategies
so in the first version of this model
there's low performance for this terms
like lesbian gay and trans the problem
is that this is also this is also
accessor baited when we look at those in
conjunction with race terms like Latin X
and so this is pretty consistent with
what users of the initial toxicity model
found as well so before developing
subsequent versions of model the team
tested the API with a various number of
gender sexual orientation or racial
racial categories in conjunction with
each other and to account for them what
they did is that they added a more toxic
training more non-toxic training
examples which contain these words to
mitigate the bias so it's a really good
example that shows testing across terms
across different contexts is important
and and also testing across terms in
which considers different cultures
identities and what we see at the end is
a more fair and inclusive product the
third challenge was avoiding or free
creating - avoiding creating and
reinforcing unfair bias is that there's
actually no standard definition of
fairness whether decisions are made by
humans or machines so the precise
definition of fairness has engendered
vibrant debates within political
philosophy in discrimination law if
anyone wants to talk John Rawls after
the talk happy to do so but it's also
the case that defining a quantitative
definition of fairness is really
difficult and that different definitions
are mathematically intractable so let's
take a look at an example so say we were
a bank and we want to grant loans to
people there's two types of people blue
in orange and say this is some kind of
protected class or sensitive class and
so we're interested in making small
loans subject to the following rules a
successful loan makes $300 but an
unsuccessful loan cost $700 and then
everyone has a credit score between 0
and 100 and so we're and then we're
going to color it as such those people
who are denied a loan but we're a
default anyway so that's going to be a
true negative that's going to be a light
gray there's people who are denied a
loan but would pay it back that's our
that's our false negative in a dark gray
and then these light blue and orange
those are people who are granted loans
but they vault so these are going to be
our false positives and then these are
and then the people who are granted
loans and pay them back and those are
our true positives okay those are the
dark believed in orange okay and if you
want to follow along there's a really
great demo on this at research that
Google at home so I speak Fisher /
attacking discrimination and m/l okay so
we have a few options here what we can
do the first thing we could do is say I
don't care about fairness constraints I
just want the most money possible okay
there's no constraints here we're just
trying to get the most profit but the
two groups have different thresholds
okay and they're held to different
standards so in this case the blue group
is at a disadvantage is it held to a
higher standard because a lot of people
who could pay back loans are being
denied loans so we have a lot of of
these these false negatives compared to
the orange case and so they actually
have different thresholds our total
profit 32,400 another constraint we
could hold us to is what's called a
group unaware we can actually hold these
two thresholds as the same we don't
necessarily care primarily about profit
maximization but we're saying let's
let's set a fair standard for each of
these let's let's in this definition
let's set the threshold equal to both
but the in this case among the people
who had payback alone the orange
represent a disadvantage okay that's
because they're ignores real differences
between the distribution of people who
can pay back their loans in between the
two groups another definition is
demographic parody that that says that
the same fractions of blue and orange
people within the blue and orange groups
get loans so the number of loans given
to each group is the same so in this
case our positive rate is 37% between
the two but the blue group is actually
at a disadvantage that's because it only
looks at the loans given not not at the
rates at which the loans are paid back
so this results in fewer qualified
people in the blue group being given
loans than in the Orangery and lastly
there is the principle of equal
opportunity the same fractions within
the blue and orange group are given two
loans of the people who can pay them
back so in this case we're looking at
the true positive rate 67 percent we're
trying to equalize the threshold such
that the true positive rates are equal
in this case this is 66 68 percent and
one of the people would pay back a loan
the blue and orange groups do you
equally well so it's about as profitable
as the Marik parody and amount about as
many people look at the loans overall
and so to sum up the group Ida we're
constraint holds that thresholds are the
same the demographic parity constraint
requires that the same percentage within
each subgroup which will receive the
loan
and the equal opportunity constraint
requires that the same fractions within
each subgroup you can pay them off will
receive the loan and I want to emphasize
that none of these definitions is
necessarily better than the other each
of them have different mathematical
properties and you can't satisfy them
all at once and which constraint you
choose depends a lot on the context of
the ML use case and the humans involved
and so in another study by Alice
Woodruff and her team investigated how
members of potentially affected
communities feel about algorithmic
fairness they asked different groups
what's an appropriate definition of
unfairness it turns out it varies a lot
depending on who you're speaking to
and their ethical legal and economic
priorities so things are considered
ethical and moral comparatives legal
requirements regular regulatory risk
populations and brand risk user trust
agreements with local communities and
markets and much much more so unfairness
is not immediately obvious and it
requires asking nuanced social political
and ethical questions
it takes a holistic analysis to consider
which definition of fairness is
appropriate for your project so now I've
talked to you about the research we've
done on fairness and machine learning I
want to present to you two tools that
you can actually help and use right now
to help you mitigate bias in your own AI
and m/l applications the first is the
facets tool and what facets is it's a
tool for exploratory data analysis where
you can come it has two robust
visualizations to aid in understanding
and analyzing machine learning data sets
you can get a sense of the shape of each
feature in your data using facets
overview and you can explore individual
observations using facets dive so over
you this is the overview visualization
gives you a quick understanding of the
distribution of values across the
features in your data sets so you can
uncover several uncommon or uncommon in
common issues such as unexpected feature
values missing feature values for a
large number observations training
serving skew and training
test validation sets Q so you can dive
into this and so this is the UCI adult
census data set that many of you have
probably seen but if you don't it's it's
a pop it's a publicly drawn data set on
the US census from 1994 and you can see
a lot of these missing values in capital
loss and the distribution plots of each
of these facets die provides an
interactive interface for exploring the
relationship between data points across
all different all of the different
features of a data set so each
individual term in the visualization
represents a data point either both on
the left and the right the left is that
is an image data set the right is the
the UCI data set you can position items
by faceting them or bucketing them in
multiple dimensions by their feature
values so some success stories that
we've seen of dive included detection of
classifier failure
identification of systemic failures
evaluating ground truth and potential
new signals for ranking so you can see
in the data set on the Left we're
checking for accurate classifications of
images and we can look for these cases
in which a class has been a cat has been
misclassified as a frog you can kind of
see some frogs in there in the data set
on the right we're able to split up the
the census data set by age spins and
marital status and we can change those
bin sizes and numbers of categories
quickly easily so that's slicing into
your training test and validation data
how about looking into the model itself
and that's where the what-if tool comes
into play what if is actually a part of
tensor board so you get automatically if
you train jobs on the Google cloud
machine learning engine so what if was a
collaboration of the tensorflow team and
the pair the people and AI research
teams so with a what-if tool you can
compare a data point through the most
similar point where your model predicts
a different results okay so if you're
familiar with causal inference this is
kind of like if you were looking at
and like a potential outcome of someone
that was had very similar types of
characteristics so we so called such
points counterfactuals and they can shed
lights on the decision boundaries of
your model or you can edit a data point
by hand an example or how a models
prediction changes so in the screenshot
here on the tools being used on a binary
classification model that predicts
whether a person earns more than fifty
thousand dollars or whether they earn
less so in this case for the selected
data point the model predicted with 73
percent confidence that the person earns
more than fifty thousand dollars the
tool automatically located the most
similar person in the data set for which
some all predicted earnings of less than
50k and compares the two side-by-side so
in this case with just a minor
difference in age and occupation changed
Amala prediction has flipped so you can
actually edit these individual points
and then run your inference again and
see what changes there's a lot more
things you can do - what if you can
explore auto-generated partial dependent
dependency plots for individual features
of a selected data point that show the
change in inference results for
different valid values of the feature
for classification models you can
explore model performance interactively
using thresholds ROC curves numerical
completion matrices and cost ratios and
something that I think is really
interesting is that you can actually
slice your data into subgroups and test
these different algorithmic fairness
constraints that we were talking about
earlier so you can look at different
things like Equal Opportunity
demographic parity and grouper underwear
including several ones that we didn't
talk about already okay so where do we
go from here well we also have a lot of
resources that were growing in terms of
education and training so one thing you
can check out is our machine learning
crafts crash course that we have that's
publicly available on our developers
site and now includes a module on
fairness and within that module you can
explore quantitative fairness in a
notebook like environment using Cola
you can also check out the first course
in our Coursera inclusive ml module and
the first course is called how Google
does ml okay so you have a module
committed to inclusive machine learning
where we go into much more detail for
designing for inclusion and fairness
constraints and how to design fair and
inclusive ml for everyone and you can
also learn more if you want to get
involved in the community
google has a set of responsible AI
practices that is always being updated
on things that we're doing and points to
resources you can also check out the
inclusive ml guide that we have that
comes along for google cloud oto mo that
we that we that we put together
principles of inclusive ml we've worked
on this a bit and then supporting groups
including women in NLP ethics NLP Lacan
AI Latin X and AI in queer and AI and
we've also been working with the
algorithmic fairness and opacity working
group at UC Berkeley okay with that
thank you so much for the opportunity
and I really look forward to your
questions
thank you Alex any questions
hi thank you very much for your thought
I actually have two questions the first
one is well is a little bit of data so
do you have any statistics on how many
fairness mistakes we've made if they are
decreasing or increasing or are the same
or something like that and the second is
how many philosophers does Google hire
that's such a good question um okay so
the first is that do we have a catalog
of fairness mistakes for making that's a
that's a hard question to answer one
because fairness again is hard to
identify and among different fairness it
depends how you define fairness so for
instance one of the examples there was a
the article on the compass algorithm
which which is had been used for
pretrial risk assessments and in that
case
ProPublica the nonprofit journalism
police outfit had done an analysis to
show that there was a difference between
and what in black defendants here and in
in in in how they overestimated black
black defendants Northpoint the company
that created it respondent said no no he
didn't but they were using a different
type of fairness definition for this so
to actually identify holistically how
many fairness violations that we have
been they think that's a super hard
question to answer and defining the
problem in the academic community is
something that's still going about your
second question how many philosophers
does Google employee there's one
philosopher that we work with her name
is Shannon valor
she's a earthy she's a virtue ethicist
at Santa Clara University and she has
been writing on tech and ethics for few
decades I want to say now we've also got
a few people who have who also are have
philosophy backgrounds but she's uh
she's kind of the
you probably the only true philosopher
that we have working winces but it's
yeah so if you're a philosopher know
somebody thank you so much for your very
important talk and all your excellent
work in the space my question is not
quite as thoughtful more operational can
you share any case studies or experience
where you've had to work with data
scientists where they prefer to for
natural language processing models for
instance they just want to get as much
data as possible throw even more at it
aggregated enhance it make it larger and
larger and expect that the bias will
somehow normalize and sort of be raced
off because you've got a larger data set
how have you addressed if any if you've
had a case example that you can share
where you've said now here are some of
the things that you need to do
tactically right right that's a great
question and I unfortunately don't have
any stories in which I've I've done that
kind of work to work with data
scientists and say you know where are
you looking at this but I think I think
I you know an advice for data scientists
to consider where the data is coming
from what but to think through the
potential biases in which where the data
are coming from and test those in
certain ways that address things like
sensitive groups and characteristics and
that may address the lack of good data
for particular groups like that but yeah
I unfortunately don't have kind of
hands-on stories
I think I think that's I think it's an
important step and I think it also needs
to happen throughout I would say that I
I want to resist the impulse of saying
that testing for fairness is one kind of
checkbox that you do and at the end the
more of it it exists at each point at
the data pipeline greetings first of all
to tie a couple things together from
graduated from university of madison
with a degree in philosophy and computer
science to tie in another question had
to do computer science because there
were no philosopher wanted ads the
question over the holidays I had a
spirited conversation with a relative
who's a Fox News kind of a person and in
this conversation I said so what is the
textbook definition of socialism it
could not give it to me cuz I had
studied some economics at Wisconsin so
you know the textbook definition of it
so when it comes to toxic language
knowing that we don't even know our own
English language is there any
sensitivity to toxicity knowing that
some people use a word that they don't
even understand so that's a that's a
really important that's a really good
point so considering the kind of the
context around language and the fact
that even some words are used in
different ways and become mobilized in
different ways I can't speak extensively
to the toxicity model and what the what
the work that is done I think some of
the work that the jigsaw team has done
and published has focused on that but I
think that that does highlight the way
that certain words gain undue
associations so it might be the case
where you know you you you see tweets
that come from certain Fox News hosts
who tweet this is what socialism is and
then certain actual socialists going
like yeah that sounds great you know so
and so I think there is a risk there and
having a single model and saying this is
a single score depending on that context
but I can't speak to the specifics of
how the toxicity model so I encourage
you to going to go to
check out jigsaws work and see what the
work they've done around it to get a
sense of how they've handled that any
more questions
guess two things I would think there be
certain sort of practices by some social
science Sciences such as anthropology
which kind of dealt with trying to look
at certain societal practices critical
gaze is there any type of kind of
practices from social sciences which
might be applicable to what we're trying
to accomplish and then at the same time
I would think there's we need to be
asking what type of societal practices
are we trying to not reinforce not
perpetuate for instance are we not
trying to perpetuate discrimination
racism so if you're looking at
predictive policing I mean you don't
want to look at crime statistics you
want to see how a community has been
redline for instance would be an example
so really thinking critically at the
front end about power kind of framing
the questions that we're trying to ask
yeah so those are really really
important questions so one the first
question is what kind of ways have
social scientists been doing
investigations or abroad a critical lens
to the field of this kind of field of
fairness and technology with that what
that is that a good operation of the
question okay so I'd say yeah so one
thing that one community that Google's
been part of is called the fairness
accountability and transparency
community that has a conference later
this month and that is an effort to
bring together both computer scientists
social scientists and legal scholars to
talk about different definitions of
fairness not only in technology itself
and the data but also in practices and
developing data science teams and what
the field looks like overall and so
that's that's one venue I think where
research is being done and within Google
we have a set of social scientists that
also work to come
from different disciplines such as
information information science
psychology in sociology as a sociologist
yes the latter a lot of questions about
whether like what what our what our
goals are basically as you know how what
are we doing here you know we're not
only and we're not only trying to we're
not only trying to develop tools which
reflect the existing distribution of a
call of inequality but what we're trying
to do have tools which are fair and
inclusive for whomever uses them and so
fairness rule you know fairness itself
you know one view of fairness is that
you is ameliorated Emile ative and I
think we move more from fairness they're
more into a conversation about justice
so that's a you know whether the weather
tools can be used for that is I think
it's a it's a it's a good discussion and
I think it's one that's happening within
the fairness accountability and
transparency community right now so I
think that's a really important point
kind of question so thank you both for
the talk and for the introduction so
I've seen both what if and facets
showing up you know here and there the
people using them so I guess my question
is say I've I have a data set and I find
this algorithm I'm I'm going through
exploring with either of those tools or
with you know whatever other
visualization libraries and I discover
oh there's there's a bias here that I
think is unfair what what do you think
is a good way to rectify that is it in
somehow doing active learning like we
heard about yesterday really fine-tuning
what what data do I send do I choose to
train on or is it more a matter of like
adjusting cost functions or I guess
what's what sort of that next step after
you discover or is silence
I think sometimes we've seen that
there's questions my google home refuses
to answer so right yeah that's I think
it depends a lot on your context in your
case I there's no one-size-fits-all in
terms of it in terms of toxicity we saw
that they added more non-toxic training
data for each of those identities where
there's Latin xquery atlantic's gay so
that might be one thing it might be the
case that you want to optimize for in a
an equality of opportunity and in a
binary classification test and I think
that depends a lot on thinking through
how users are going to be affected and
really understanding that what what
those was so what that's going to be so
for instance in the lone case are you
know there's the the interests of the
you as the bank but there's also the
interests of the users and and in the
people getting the loan and people been
what are the considerations of people
being denied a loan how's that going to
affect their lives compared to how much
happening with with with the person
making decisions and so there's a great
paper that's being published at fat star
by Ben Hutchinson and Meg Mitchell who
are on the ML Fairness team that sort of
has a dividing line and kind of
considers what is like kind of what
different definitions of fairness do
from kind of this perspective of who is
and like who who it impacts in some kind
of way and they divide these into
different different statistical
definitions so I'm going to give you a
very social science type of answer it's
very contextual alright thanks again
Alex
[Applause]